how do I make this a six figure business
what do I prioritize so you're targeting
the people who like can't afford a
bookkeeper yet but are making mistakes
themselves and don't know what to do
when you're like frustrated with the
software and like maybe you feel
overwhelmed by the numbers and
everything else yeah the problem with
that is because of getting a mid six
figure business you need such scale
because those people don't have money so
the fastest way to get to Mid six
figures is solve a big problem for
people with money because you need fewer
people so it's not that that can't work
you just need a lot more people to be
able to get it to Mid six figures the
mission is so much bigger than working
with 10 clients or 20 clients but when
you're making mid six figures that
allows you a lot more freedom to then
make content at scale even if you never
get paid for it because I know your
heart your passion is to help the
content becomes free that can help
everybody all of the new customers but
you need money to pay for all of that so
if you're making mid six figures in your
business then you can do whatever you
want on the content side of things
and financial coach and a lot of my
content has been around Financial
education yet what's helping mostly
newcomers who are coming to Canada but I
have recently decided to Pivot and one
of the last activities we did in
movement makers I
My Future Self was telling me things and
so I have decided to Pivot a little bit
and focus more on the B2B side of things
so it's working with growing businesses
to start and Implement an accounting
system and then do like the training the
bookkeeping stuff and things like that
not doing the actual bookkeeping but
doing the training for them so they
could take over a lot of things by
themselves and so the question is how do
I make this a six figure business what
do I prioritize you're trying to train
entrepreneurs on how to do their own
bookkeeping yes a little bit of that so
it's pretty much so most people would
put their systems in Excel or eventually
they want to get into an accounting
system and they would be like okay I
want my CPA to take care of this and
everything but most CPAs don't even want
to take care of that booking side of
things they just want to get like the
file that's ready and do their stuff but
most of them because most of those most
entrepreneurs would not know what to do
they would you know they just hand up a
lot of things so the thing I'm trying to
serve is help those people who are then
transitioning or who are growing to
start and Implement their systems and
train them on the basic things that they
could do like most of the softwares
right now you can access them on your
phones so it's a matter of teaching them
those basic things that they could do
including sales taxes and stuff that
they could do on their own
um I could stay on to provide like
ongoing support and stuff but I'm not
actually taking on their bookkeeping to
do and the CPAs and not concerned with
doing maintaining the books they just
mean concerned with giving the tax
advice the high level stuff so it's that
little thing that I'm
that I'm gonna focus on okay I hear you
and the question was how do you turn
that into a six-figure business as soon
as possible um
let's go I love it okay so here's the
thing the the problem that you're
solving requires a lot of people
and at the beginning what I mean by that
is like the the entrepreneurs who have
money have their own bookkeepers already
right like we have a bookkeeper we have
an accountant we have a lawyer we have
all the professionals lined up the
people who don't yet have a bookkeeper
uh
at the beginning of themselves and
they're probably getting screwed on
their taxes and but it doesn't matter
that much because the dollar figures are
so low
so you're targeting the people who like
can't afford a bookkeeper yet but are
making mistakes themselves and don't
know what to do when you're like
frustrated with the software and like
maybe feel overwhelmed by the numbers
and everything else the problem with
that is uh in terms of getting a mid six
figure business you need such scale
because those people don't have money
so the fastest way to get to Mid six
figures is solve a big problem for
people with money
because you need fewer people right so
it's not that that can't work you just
need a lot more people to be able to get
it to Mid six figures how much would you
charge for that service depends on the
level of mess that's in there so oh the
part I didn't say was also some of them
already have like really really messy
files
um so there's a fee for an accountant
but that's not what you're doing like
you're not helping actually submit the
books and everything so bookkeeping
services which is what you know you have
done for clients what is that range for
on even an annual basis like from
obviously there's a range but like what
is the what is the range
charge for bookkeeping services well the
rate that you would see going in general
in the market it's somewhere in the
neighborhoods of
thirty dollars to about 60 dollars an
hour what do you charge 75 okay 75 an
hour great uh and then what would that
for an average client look like per
month or per year
depends on the business
on average it's about two to four
thousand dollars per client per month
two to four thousand per client per
month okay so
that's if they want full service
bookkeeping services right like you're
going to take care of all the
bookkeeping for them
yes if you're getting somebody and stuff
for example it's a full-time salary or
you're keeping somebody on an ongoing
basis it's like okay ongoing retainer
which is at least maybe like
500 maybe a month
right and most people don't have
full-time bookkeepers on staff they'd
hire somebody whether it's 500 a month
or hiring you is 3 000 a month on
average right
so but the new service that you're
thinking about doing is for somebody who
can't afford three thousand a month
because if they could afford their 3000
a month they don't want to do it
themselves they want to hire Ida to do
it right so now to make that happen we
have to be charging Less Than 3 000 a
month
yes right
so we're trying getting them to do more
of their things that they could do so
now I think it's a matter of skill
so let's say it's a thousand a month
right and a thousand a month you could
still hire a bookkeeper for but whatever
let's say it's a thousand a month if you
want to build so if your your current
service is 3 000 a month your new
service is maybe a thousand a month of
training okay if you want to build a mid
six figure business off of a thousand
dollars a month per person
you need a lot of people to sign up for
this new thing
versus and it's it's not that it's not
doable it's just it's a lot of uh it's a
lot of work and they eventually leave
you because they hire a bookkeeper which
which may be you but the whole idea is
as they scale and grow they don't want
to be doing the bookkeeping it's good
for them to learn and have the
understanding but they don't want to be
doing the bookkeeping right every
entrepreneur it's like the first thing
that entrepreneurs want to give up is
the bookkeeping
you hate it I hate it
so to get to Mid six figure business
that's where the it's you need to scale
pretty hard
um and what I love doing it doesn't mean
it has to be your path is how do I solve
a big problem for somebody who has money
so that I can get to my goal faster so
when we brought into the movement makers
like
um Drew and Zach and like people sharing
their story the starting price is 2 000
a month and that scales to like 10 000 a
month
because they're solving a problem for
somebody who has money so then if you're
making five six thousand a month per
client to get to a mid six figure
business we just need 10 clients
and then you're there right
um you're gonna need
a lot more so
not to discourage you or that that it's
not a fit it's just do you want that
business model of
you you're training people you're
solving a problem but it's a lower level
problem and they're eventually going to
leave you
because their business grow I don't know
how long they stay with you a year six
months before like they've learned it or
they've scaled so that they can just
hire somebody
okay so what do you think would then be
a better direction to go with this
what is a problem that people with money
have
and how can you solve it I know quite a
good number of people with money who
have messy accounting systems because
they have terrible bookkeepers and their
CPAs find it extremely hard to work with
them what might be great is and the
mission is so much bigger than working
with 10 clients or 20 clients right but
when you're making mid six figures that
allows you a lot more freedom to then
make content at scale even if you never
get paid for it
right because I know your heart your
passion is to help especially the
newcomers coming who like how would a
thousand dollars a month is insane like
there's no way they can afford that so
the content becomes free that can help
everybody all of the new customers but
you need you need money to pay for all
of that right so if you're making mid
six figures in your business then you
can do whatever you want on the content
side of things
um so if the problem is most bookkeepers
suck if you want a phone say that but
whatever
I've met quite a few quite a few yeah
then then it could be having like what
makes a great bookkeeper in having it be
uh
Ida approved like who are the Ida
approved bookkeepers you take you could
do the same thing that I'm doing with
Jeremy and and Drew and Zach and they
are effectively YouTube Consultants
right they're gonna come in and help you
grow your YouTube channel
and there's a lot of crappy YouTube
Consultants there's a lot of people who
say they can help and they suck right
everybody's a YouTube consultant great
so same thing everybody can be a
bookkeeper great but it doesn't mean
you're actually any good and a lot of
entrepreneurs may not know the
difference between a good one and a bad
one right so
if you love somebody
um the the model would be you take a
piece of their business and mentor and
train the bookkeepers so you take some
bookkeepers you train them up on how to
become a good bookkeeper that falls
under the Ida brand that why does
somebody sign up with uh Zach who's
who's a new YouTube consultant well
because it's from my brand
right and then you take a commission off
of the entire business so you take a 25
royalty fee off of the entire Revenue in
the business
and then you meet them once a week like
this is what I do with Drew and
everybody else we meet once a week on a
Monday and talk about their business
where are you struggling how can I help
how are our clients what are our goals
what are the three things that you know
you need some feedback on and I'm
helping them build and grow their
business
there's messaging in between and stuff
but it's it's basically 25 minutes every
week on a Monday
and that could be pretty high leverage
for you and that if you find
two three four five people that you love
as humans and you're gonna train them on
how to be a better bookkeeper and then
you're doing venturing calls with them
and introducing them to potential
clients where then when you're meeting
all these entrepreneurs even better
meeting the CPAs the CPAs take working
with crappy bookkeepers
it just makes their life impossible
because they can only do so much it's
like if your books are a disaster what's
the CPA going to do and the good ones go
in and try to teach and try to help or
try to understand it's like man if you
just hired a good bookkeeper this would
all be so much easier for everybody
that's the point I was trying to to then
be the person but the thing that was to
flip it and not be the person but be the
person training this whole group of
bookkeepers to take care of that problem
right right but you so you can either do
like the mass the mass way would be to
have the Ida training that is a course
or that is group coaching or whatever
and bookkeepers join for whatever 500 a
month and you're training them and
coaching them or you have your course
that's five thousand dollars or whatever
and training them and coaching them
um and you can read all aspects of
business too like how do you get clients
and how do you grow and how do you
maintain relationships and as well as
the CPA side of like here's what CPAs
are looking for you here's how to this
is like the the skills of the book The
keeping the books and then the skills of
growing a business
but again if you're if you have a if
you're selling a five thousand dollar
course which is fairly expensive if you
want to make mid six figures a year you
got to sell a lot of courses
vertices and that's still possible but
maybe like if you said I want to get
those Mystic figures as soon as possible
I wouldn't go that path because it takes
so long to build that up versus if you
take five people
train them work with them get them a
call every Monday and you're taking 25
percent of the revenue that comes in on
that business in exchange for mentoring
them teaching them making introductions
for them then if they're all building
like if if you're taking 25 revenue and
you get four bookkeepers and help them
build their mid six figure business then
you have a mid-security business
not been there
and it's working with four people now
you have to love them right like I love
working with you if I if I saw on Monday
and I saw Drew on there like oh my God I
gotta talk to you again this guy I hate
right like it wouldn't work so you have
to really pick the people who you
partner with I don't maybe you already
know some people have in mind who you
think might be a good fit to work with
but that's the fastest path it's like
people who are making money and we're
solving a big problem for them you you
actually can't solve a huge problem
people's books are a mess even people
even entrepreneurs who are making
millions of dollars of books are a
disaster and the CPA basically saves
them every year and they're like
massively stressed out around tax time
it's like can you just please hire a
good bookkeeper yeah and the
entrepreneur doesn't want to do the work
to think like the first question is
going to be okay who do you recommend
who should I hire and the CP is like I
don't know
right so that's where it's like higher
Ida but Ida is so busy United doesn't
want more clients I just kind of get out
of the business so instead of higher Ida
it's like higher Ida's person and if you
went to all the CPAs that you've worked
with and said hey I'm I'm starting a
bookkeeping Network and I'm personally
training people how to be great
bookkeepers
if you have any extra business let me
know and I'll pass it to my team because
I work with them I'm on a call every
week with them and and it flows through
me it's under my brand then um people be
much likely to like you might have all
the businesses you need just from that
makes sense that doesn't take you to
like a mid-seven figure business but it
takes you to a mid six figure business
which then frees up a lot of your time
and energy and finances and freedom to
then go make content make your courses
make a group thing train entrepreneurs
at a you know 500 a month or something
um to do all the bigger things that
you've got because you're you have money
coming in
okay
makes sense
what makes a lot of sense what's hard
like if you said if you had
um like how many how much time do you
put into your like you actually doing
bookkeeping one day a week okay if you
went to CPAs all your contacts and said
hey I'm five days a week now how how
quickly could you fill up those five
days
pretty quick
perfect okay that's that's the harder
problem so like the marketing is not the
problem you don't have to go take out
ads you don't have to go on podcasts you
don't have to go on radio stations or
something you can already fill up your
calendar with business if you wanted to
yes so now if you went to those same
people and said I'm not doing it but
I've I've trained people on how to do it
and I mentor and guide them you could
fill up their rosters pretty quick
yes the challenge would be to find those
people yes so that's the next that
becomes your most important challenge
you need four people who you're gonna
help to build up to help them create a
mid-six figure business so that you can
have your mid six to your business off
of taking 20 25 Revenue
so now it's thinking who Do You Love
who's who's okay but has a lot of
potential who is coachable who when you
talk to
you feel you know good about
it's energizing they still need training
they still need work
and then that becomes your new Monday or
your new Tuesday or whatever not even
it's only four people like the model
that I run is for we have we've got how
many people five how many people are
doing
right okay I love it too though but but
if you needed four people if you wanted
a mid six figure business and you need
to help four people get to Mid six
figure business and then you've got your
mid-60 business so in that model you
could have
25 I do 25 minute meetings this is
basically two hours a week to mentoring
people on calls
plus like DMS and emails and like
whatever
problems they might have but uh it's two
hours a week to do those four people
so now you gotta go find those four
people and you can scale it harder you
could do eight if you wanted to and then
that's four hours a week so Biz Dev in
this one then is
walk me through the business of this one
then
foreign
you have enough clients coming in right
like if you were mentioning eight people
and then you couldn't fill up their
business enough then it becomes the biz
Dev show to get clients
but when I asked you if you're a one day
a week and you're gonna go to five and
you said you could fill that up pretty
quickly then you don't need you don't
this Dev is not your problem you have
enough Biz coming in
right
and the way that that worked I mean you
know this but for everybody watching on
the replay uh it's very much a referral
business that if that if those CPAs end
up loving you and they love the people
that you're working with then they start
just sending more business
because you're making the CPA's life
easier and
the entrepreneur who's hiring a CPA will
listen to their CPA like we we got our
bookkeeper from our accountant
it's like you need you need a bookkeeper
okay
who we use this person great yeah that's
how it usually works that's how it works
and then the bookkeeper would have to
like massively screw up to not get the
deal right
so the the biz Dev would become getting
to know more accountants but that's not
your immediate problem your problem is I
need to get I need to get the Junior
bookkeepers and like train them up to
get better yes
because if I went to an accounting firm
right like there's a lot of them if I
just go to them they would they are
willing to just let it go
yeah yeah they have a lot that they want
to let go so that's the immediate
homework is how do I find four people
who I could train and that becomes a
deal it's like it's a pretty high margin
business and so we want to focus on
we're not doing 10 an hour bookkeeping
we're doing 75-hour booking or 100 an
hour bookkeeping like we're we're
charging more first being affiliated
with I with Ida means you charge more
same thing with like YouTube Consulting
right
it's not a it's not a 200 a month thing
like you're starting at two thousand
dollars a month
I want my the minimum is 500 an hour for
for what we do if if any any of your
programs or packages or whatever that
I'll I'll tell you and everybody if it's
under 500 an hour then it's not enough
margin
500 an hour minimum right
um
so whatever if you're at 100 an hour or
75 hours an hour you help them get to
100 an hour even 75 is high now if you
take them to 100 they're still making
great money at this at they get the 75
and you get the 25 for training them and
being part of the brand and bringing in
business
perfect so how do you find the four
people to train
anybody you know work
I've been looking for them
oh my goodness is there like a do you
have to be licensed
no you could be but you don't have to be
you just have to be good okay
one like
nobody checks or cares because it's it's
your name on the line
no it's not a regulated profession as in
so so calling yourself a CPA or calling
yourself a certified bookkeeper that is
like a a professional thing but you
don't need any of those to do the work
right but you need to be to be a a CPA
certified yes or a lawyer or whatever
exactly so yeah yeah so that's great so
that becomes like how quickly if
somebody was passion and eager to learn
how quickly could you take them to to do
the things that they need to know how to
do I don't know
yeah no it's fast because like even when
I'm training clients I train people for
like a two to four hour period and they
know enough to kind of
go they wouldn't know how to solve
problems so whenever problems come up
they still need to call me but in terms
of like being able to just take it and
start putting in the stuff the correct
way a couple of hours so maybe two to
four hours in one day so let's say to
train a good bookkeeper to know the
things that to do the things right
within the week it should be it should
you should be able to to get up and go
from what what's their starting point
knowing nothing of a bookkeeping knowing
nothing about bookkeeping to
implementing the methods I teach you yes
a week ah then you just need somebody
who would hustle and like wants to learn
yes
I mean I did this for Jeremy Jeremy was
my first test in this whole thing and he
he was a grocery store worker earning
minimum minimum wage like stocking
shelves at a local grocery store and I
said I'm going to teach you YouTube and
I made him do some research first I go I
was on tour so I go watch these videos
so that you have a basic understanding
and then I started teaching him and then
he started doing free client calls
um yeah now like he's he if he wanted to
good at seven figures this year he's
kind of not lazy but he doesn't he
doesn't want to hit it's fine
right and that's in like three years
when did we start with Jeremy 2019 yeah
um
yeah and so if you have people who who
you can just ambitious people and new
customers are great for that too because
like they're looking for something
they're they're willing to hustle so
somebody who you just love working with
and say hey do you want to build a
mid-six figure bookkeeping business
together and I'll show you what you need
to do and if it takes a week to get them
trained
maybe not a hundred percent but you're
still there to answer questions and
solve problems and whatever
um then the amount of work that you do
per person will start to is that is the
onboarding and then it falls out pretty
quickly until most of the problems 98 of
the problems will be solved because they
know how to do it yeah and that final
two percent is that's why they're still
talking to you every Monday
to get guidance
um yeah if you could change somebody in
a week you just need some hard-working
people who are willing to learn yeah
that's that's the key word right people
who are willing to hustle because I know
my work ethic I know when I set my mind
to do something I'll do it so if it's a
person who is like okay either I'm I'm
in I want to learn it I want to do this
a week is all you need with me and you
can
yep
so and you want somebody local like you
want somebody in Montreal it doesn't
have to be local ideally well no it
doesn't have to be local I train people
I train people on zoom and teams and
stuff like that it doesn't have to be
local somebody in Canada or like ideally
Canada because come to think about it
this thing the things which are very
specific to Canada the sales taxes every
single province has a different rule
regarding sales tax and so just things
like that if you're in Canada at least
you get to understand things a little
bit better well not necessarily I think
that's a bias but it's just easier to
train somebody who's local in Canada
versus somebody who's not here but it's
not impossible I guess
to train from anywhere
I mean I love the Immigrant mindset and
mentality I mean like people want to
work and they want an opportunity and
they're probably not getting it doing
something else like most people when
they first come to Canada unless they've
already got a job lined up they're doing
pretty crappy jobs and here you are
giving them a knowledge worker job plus
plus you're awesome at welcoming
newcomers in you know uh you'll be a
good kind of Mentor so if you wanted
local Montreal you could like where are
the people coming into from Montreal I
mean two Montreal from around the world
that you want to go and train if you're
Canada then there's tons of people
coming into
like the Toronto immigration scene is
huge they need to help
um we've done a lot of work with Kiva I
think you know Kiva uh it's like micro
loan programs and my sister helped me
start it and most of the loans that we
do go to various countries uh in Africa
and it's always the women that they give
the loans to maybe not always now but
like how it started it's like the women
were the ones who were like gave the
loans to because they uh were more
likely to pay it back more likely to do
the work uh I'm more likely to like hold
each other accountable as well too so I
think there's definitely something great
in your story and like you being an
immigrant to Canada finding other people
who have a similar story and then saying
hey like I want to let me teach you
beyond just the stuff that you're
already teaching around credit scores
and paying your credit card off on time
and which debt to pay off first and all
that generic Financial advice which is
still like insanely badly needed because
people are making really terrible
Financial choices to find a couple of
those people even local
like just hanging out where all the new
immigrants are hanging out where do they
come like when they first land here
where are they going
um with other family members or friends
they're going to host uh host families
let's say but are there
um
government resources or
newcomer events or well thinking about
Meister when I got you I didn't get to
use any of those government things so I
I leave to the host family and
events there are some not many people
attend those anyway but yes there are
some like
settlement organizations that would host
lots of activities when people just come
over so they could get orientation as to
okay this is what you do these are the
kind of things and stuff like that yeah
so how did you find your host family
um a friend my sister's friend
was here in Montreal
okay so like it's those networks plus
how can you get to know all the host
families in Montreal oh that's like keep
figuring out trying to know everybody
who lives in Montreal you can't again
like you don't need everybody okay you
need four people or you need to start
with one person
right because you could get one person
and you build them to a four hundred
thousand dollar a year business you have
a hundred thousand dollar your business
I just got an idea okay okay this makes
sense so yeah yeah no that makes a lot
of sense okay wait listen
um I'm listening I'm here okay
most of the immigrants were coming over
on the like the skilled worker program
like I did they already have the
Bachelors or Masters and they have like
work experience in their various
countries there are a lot of accountants
from home from out of Canada who are not
able to get hired here because they know
nothing about it those would probably be
the easiest people to train in the
bookkeeping because they already have a
background knowledge in accounting and I
was just about taking that and making it
Canadian so it's about where do I find
those people those could probably be the
first group of people I bring and I said
okay those are the people I'm gonna
train to take on this gay it be in the
network
yeah like are they using immigrant
lawyers like how are they getting
through and
those are the people that you want to
connect with okay
it's still more the mindset because if
even if they have the knowledge they
know how to use a general ledger you
know like that kind of stuff
um how much are they open to learning
from you
because it's true a lot of people come
from my my acupuncturist with a surgeon
back in China but
came here and like didn't want to go
through all of the
training and everything to become a
doctor so he just became an
acupuncturist because it's not not it's
less regulated or not regulated
um
so yeah finding those people again you
don't you could build this into
something bigger if you really liked it
right you could take on 20 people that
you mentored then maybe you need a Biz
Dev show to get more accountants on to
get more business into what you're doing
um
but it's really just finding your first
four people okay
I still want to see you make content but
like this is not a Content play right
like but what it does is you know again
once you're making two three four five
hundred thousand dollars a year it just
frees up so much more to do all the
content and all the ideas and all the
courses and all the masks because the
idea that you started with is is a great
idea it's just at scale you need you
need scale you need Mass to make it
happen or the stuff you're posting on
Tick Tock and everything else is great
it's it's designed for a mass audience
so you're making very little the models
make very little off of a lot of people
which is a great model but it takes so
long to build up where most even you
look at Tesla they started with the
Roadster the expensive car and then they
went to now now they're going Mass but
every car becomes a little bit cheaper
um and so same thing like the fastest
way to get to a six-figure business mid
six figure business
Friday is uh sell the people who have
money and you're solving a big problem
because entrepreneurs with multi-million
dollar companies still have crappy bucks
and is a nightmare for the CPAs to work
with so like solve that problem and it
gives you the money to solve all the
other problems too perfect
let's go Ida I got my orders all right
you got your marching orders uh
yeah it it and it's fun you know it's
fun and it's it's fun to see taking
somebody who nobody else is betting on
and they have a mid
six figure business because they met you
yeah
wow you know whatever in 2018 I think
I I wrote something down this I wrote
bookkeepers in training that was a
Facebook group I created like four or
five years ago and I shut it down I
never did anything with it but this is
pretty much it get people train them in
bookkeeping and then they do the work
and I'm the one training them because I
know I'm very good at that it's
something I've done a lot but I never
like thought about building this model
around it and you've got heart and
you've got patience and I think you'll
be great at it the difference is we're
not selling we're not selling the
training we're investing in their
business
because bookkeepers in training could be
its own business where you're giving
them a five thousand dollar course or
something which is still another that
could be phase two or phase three
but phase one is I'm going to invest in
your business and I'm gonna take four
people and Mentor you and show you how
to do this and let's make money together
and I uh have started having people ask
me to coach them and help them and and
really spend some time in the lockdown
thinking about what the next step is in
my journey and
um I this year I decided I wanted to be
a speaker author coach so I'm writing a
book
um I've
um just got certified as a high
performance coach with Brendan's Group
which is how I found you by the way cool
and um just thinking about how do I
launch a thought leader career
um I fell in love with doing videos I do
listening videos sell houses and
um really love being in front of the
camera it turns out and so yeah so I'm
super pumped about building I've got a
um here in Denver I have a Denver office
and a boulder office but in this office
I've already built out a little uh maybe
it's 12 by 12 room for a studio all
right I have gear purchased I have no
excuses
um just learning how to get it all set
up I have
um acoustic tiles on the walls I have
Lighting on the way you know I'm doing
the whole thing and um what I'm really
hoping to do is put out video content
um to start to build first of all
momentum from my book
um I was a millionaire before I was 30
and then I was homeless for six years as
a drug addict so um I have and I've been
clean for 12 years now so I have a you
know I have a little bit of a journey to
share with people and
um really interested in helping people
you know like you mentioned in your book
you know help you people who've been
through the same thing but the same
thing in my case might mean somebody
who's struggling to make it as a realtor
um it might mean somebody who's been
homeless it might mean somebody's a drug
addict you know all of those people are
in my core group of people to help
whether they're Realtors or
um entrepreneurs I want to help them
build a business the way that I was able
to build a business which was really
focusing on the heart rather than the
mind so instead of top of mind
um I'm all about top of heart which is
all about making real emotional
connections with people so
I'm babbling but the the point of our
time together here is I'm really excited
to learn from you uh I have a fear and
that fear is that is not to do video my
fear is that it is mediocrity uh my fear
is that um you know I've had some
friends start YouTube channels or put
out videos and I watched them put out
you know a video five six seven times
and they go away and never do it again
because it's terrible because there's
nobody looking there's nobody watching
and I'm I'm a I'm a high achiever and uh
I expect big things and I'm afraid that
I'm going to start putting out video
nobody's going to watch and I'm going to
go away so what I need is a plan to
stick to and if you tell me do x amount
of videos this often for this long
um no matter what I'll do it
um but that's that's where I need is I
need some help with how to get started
great and and the target's going to be
real estate or or no anybody anybody
who's in sales or or marketing so really
which is you know an entrepreneur or
sales people I think that immediately uh
I can impact Realtors you know um if a
realtor hears that I've done 50 million
in real estate this year they'll want to
learn from me so I have a really good
soft you know audience right away
um and I have some people that kind of I
believe will follow what I do there but
I want to I don't want to limit it to
this real estate
got it so I would create a plan that
I would execute for all of 2021
and and you're not allowed to deviate
from it until you get to 2022. yeah
instead of judging like is it working or
not because it because YouTube
especially takes the most time to build
but is the most long-term brand building
that you can do because YouTube
is the only place for your videos will
live forever
right so we'll post you know this as an
IG live is great without some people
watching you see a couple some people
watching the replay but you know in in a
year nobody will care what happens on
your Instagram
five days later nobody cares what's
happened on your Instagram but if you're
if you're a fan of Brandon's work you
know his black and white video series
six years later are still getting views
still getting attention still getting
interest especially if the if the
content you can talk about is Evergreen
and timeless
so if you're talking about sales
principles as opposed to selling in
December 2020 sure right so I want
Evergreen kind of content and you can
definitely dive into elements of your
story I think that's fantastic
um three videos a week
you can film them all in one day if you
can get to daily that's awesome but but
uh if you're a high achiever we need to
be over one one a week three would be my
kind of minimum in
um you can fill them all on one day if
you want you know for for a couple weeks
at a time so you don't have to
go into the studio or you know three
times a week
um I wanna uh talking head video
so you talking direct the camera and you
can you can pull ideas from whoever you
think is your biggest kind of
contemporary in the YouTube world and
it's probably a mix of people there's
nobody there's no one person who's like
you so I'd pull topics from Brendan I
pull topics from my channel I pull
topics from in sales I'd be looking at
Grant Cardone I've been looking at
Jordan Belfort if you're looking at
Robert Kiyosaki if you're looking at
like whoever are the
your your bits of all these different
people go to their channels look at the
most successful videos that they've ever
done and then make your version of it
and don't don't even care what they I
don't care what they said so if you go
to Brendan's Channel or garyvee's
Channel and it's you know the advice
every 20 year old needs to hear
I want you to make that video
without watching what their advice is I
don't care what Brendan's advice is I
want grants advice so focus on the topic
take the title and take the topic
okay 10 minute plus video
damn it what
to sound so long it's okay I'm just
being honest you could you could do it
because you've you you've got knowledge
to share sure yeah I babbled at you for
10 minutes already so I'm in yeah well
Babylon is different than 10 minutes
right sure yeah yeah in in the book
there's there's the structure of how to
do a perfect thought leadership yeah
piece of content I would hone in on that
I I would guess you would be great at
your storytelling
you could easily tell a three four five
minute story or more your story client
story uh somebody you've mentored
um something you see happening with
young real estate agent sales people
addicts like there's lots of stories you
could tell I think you'd be great at
that I think the Practical advice piece
you'd probably be great at that too so
okay to solve this problem do one two
three step one do this and I'm sure you
could you've just had enough experience
you can you can even you had a point
form you could talk to those points and
be eloquent in in tons of value where
most people struggles is the opening
so you got to hit me with something that
you believe that that most people would
find different or weird
um so even this practice like what's one
thing you believe grant that other
people don't believe uh lead generation
is
great so like that's the first thing out
of your face when you press record yeah
the very first thing right so when I
work with people then they they still
press record and say hey it's welcome
back it's me Grant like no Grant yeah
right so you press a chord and like the
very first thing has to be a powerful
opinion that
like what did he just say yeah and so
that that takes some training to do but
I think most of the other stuff you'll
be great at
um so at least one video a week of the
three that is thought leadership like
that direct the camera talking uh I
would love to see one of the three be a
coaching video
okay where there's somebody in front of
you like this this is a coaching video
right but flipped so so now you're
coaching somebody who is in your office
is part of your fan group
um is an up and coming sales person is
an addict or is an addict recovery or
any of the topics that you deal with
okay and
the great part about that is you just
have to show up
there's no script there's no memorizing
anything there's no what's my first
sentence it's it's you just coaching
your your preparation is the Decades of
experience you have in this business out
and helping people so Michael you don't
really interrupt you real quick my goal
is to build a bit of a membership site
and to uh group coaching for certified
high performance so I think you've
talked about it this before so you maybe
take a snippet of somebody who's
um you know maybe there's a Facebook
maybe we have a zoom call once a month
um and I do some one-on-one in front of
everybody else for 15-20 minutes taking
a piece of that and just putting that as
YouTube content you know with their
permission of course you can do that
um and or you could do this okay where
you do it over something like Instagram
live to help build your Instagram
audience up or it could just be a a
separate Zoom that you do either for
pain members so hey as a bonus you also
get a one-on-one with Grant okay right
so if you sorry I'm sorry to interrupt
you but then do you take this and put it
back into YouTube meaning do you okay uh
is that not all of these like I have a
Daily Show here not all of them get cut
for YouTube some of them if it's really
good it'll get cut my team just decides
that which one goes up
um but yeah so I go live daily on
Instagram uh and that helps Instagram
audience and also creates content for
other potential platforms I mean this
this could get cut up into a million
different ways for different platforms
depending on what comes out of it
um but that you could have it as a bonus
so hey here's my membership and it costs
x per month but if you sign up for the
annual deal you also get a one-on-one
with Grant
that then can be turned into content
right so you use it to you can use it to
get people into your program
um if you love it and you want to do
more of it then
uh maybe you have enough members to to
back it up if not then you can do it for
free
and people get to see you coaching so
that if it's free then it's public if
it's free then it's going to be online
and some people may not want it to be
public so say okay great well I've got a
I've got a coaching package and I've got
my membership program where you can
train with me every two weeks sure right
so the free gives you the attention that
then shows off you as a coach because if
you want to sell a membership program
where you're going to be coaching people
I need to see you as a coach
right not just a thought leader talking
the camera I need to see you like get
get the Ugg bug eyes like oh my God
grant I can't believe what you just said
that saved my life right yeah
um and it's fun you know it's fun like
talking to a person not just a camera
inside a 12x12 little studio right yeah
um and then my third series would be
something around the book
so how many chapters are in the book
um 15 16. yeah so I would take that and
to turn those into 15 to 16. uh
regular themes okay but then you cycle
through
so like what's chapter one in the book
um
I don't know whatever chapter seven and
I haven't thought like the one I'm
writing right now is called scraping the
bottom so it's about hitting rock bottom
and just kind of getting dragged along
the bottom perfect instead of bouncing
off it yeah and what what chapter number
is that a seven seven perfect so seven
is scraping the bottom and so you know
every 15 16 weeks
there's going to be another video about
scraping the bottle got it and then you
just tell a different story right you've
got lots of different stories that you
can relate to you clients in the news
cycle about scraping the bottom
because I want you creating content that
relates to the book okay and then inside
those videos you can say hey and this is
also chapter seven
in my book right and it builds awareness
for the book uh without it being a hey
go buy my book kind of sales pitch every
time got it
um inside so those those would be my
three series that I would start with
that's awesome direct the camera where
you're pulling from the people who you
kind of look up to and respect uh
coaching with people who are in your
community uh and then a series around
the book
inside every video should be a call to
action to get something free first
chapter of your book for free uh bonus
video about the eight sales techniques
that can blow up your business
Howard became a millionaire before 30
like whatever whatever bonuses uh fit
best and you put it in the middle of the
video not at the beginning not at the
end but in the middle of the video
that then leads people to a landing page
and then you get their email address
because it's great to build a YouTube
channel but I want you to have a
business that's successful on top of it
not just your goal isn't to just be an
influencer right yeah absolutely so we
need to get people off of YouTube onto
uh onto our email list and then when
your book comes out then you've got a
list to be able to pitch people to
um if you want to add a fourth Series in
it would be interviews
okay
where you would try to get uh
Grant Cardone and Jordan Belfort and
Brendan burchard and whoever on the
channel do interviews and then you can
run targeted ads against their channel
to kind of hack Their audience to get
them to come on board
um even this like you could take this
interview this one-on-one
and turn it into a YouTube video and
then run it as a targeted ad against my
audience
so then people who know me they'll click
on it because they know me and then
they'll say who's this grant guy and
they learn about you and then dive down
your Channel
um if you want to add a fourth series
and then if you if you wanted to make
more then I would double down on one of
those other series I wouldn't double
down the book but I would double down on
either the coaching or the director
camera yeah if you want to go two a week
on one of those now we're talking four
or five videos a week
um again depends on how
committed UI and how serious you want to
take it but at least three of those
videos per week for all of 2021 and then
evaluate how we're doing at the end of
the year just like your mindset is where
I'm doing this three videos a week for
the entire year not oh I'm quitting in
February because exactly right yeah
that's exactly my fear how do I get
people to the YouTube channel like how
do they know it even exists right
because they're a gazillion YouTube
channels how does that
yeah so starting point one we're picking
good titles that are coming from other
channels right so that video on
Brendan's Channel about advice I give to
people in my 20s for example
um you may not ever have thought of that
as a title but you could give you could
make that video you know you could you
can come up with so we're pulling good
titles already the ultimate hope is to
show up as suggested against those
people's channels
um but Step One is picking great topics
that people care about because a lot of
times you might think oh I'm gonna make
a video on lead generation
but instead of calling it maybe using
the words lead generation sucks on
YouTube
maybe it's how to get more sales right
and so the content could be exactly the
same yeah but how you title it can make
a world of difference for how that video
performs that's huge um
two do you have an email list
no nothing zero okay so you know we got
to start building an email list yeah
yeah and anytime you come up with a new
video or series of videos you email them
the video so people can find it and I
should I shouldn't say zero you know I
have 150 people who saw me on stage
right before covid yeah are really eager
to do something with me and I've done
zero with them so great this is you know
it's time yeah hey the first 150 is the
hardest so yeah about 150 yeah you send
them links to the videos as they come up
um even better if you can put them
inside a playlist
okay
uh the link goes into a playlist yeah
I'm going to show you how I'm going to
show you a hot Grant this is great let
me show I'm going to go to my computer
I'm going to show you this right now
this is what you're gonna have to do
when you put out all your videos okay so
we're gonna go to Brendan's channel so
we've got the videos here uh and say
this one says generate energy in your
life okay like say this is your video
yeah okay
when you load the video here there's an
ID up here okay it's gonna go
youtube.com watch
question mark V equals and then this is
the ID of that video okay okay that's
the video ID
why this is so important is we're going
to go back to Brandon's Channel we're
going to click upload so we're going to
click
play all
and then this code we need to pull from
your list so up here you only have to do
this once once you get this code
we're going to take this says and list
equals
this giant thing okay
I'm going to copy that
okay then we're going back to his video
here
if I paste this at the end of this list
at the end of that link it's going to
paste it
what's going to happen is it still shows
me the video but now on the side it's
inside of a playlist wow so what's going
to happen is it says 284 videos
so you share this video
and then automatic is going to run
through 284 other videos from his
channel right and so if you only have
five videos it'll only show five videos
right but as you keep adding to it it's
going to keep adding more and more and
more and more videos in WoW
some people load the video and then just
turn it off like or they don't turn off
the computer but they go for lunch or
something and they come back oh I just
ended up watching 30 of Grant's videos
in the background yeah which all helps
with the algorithm people find out about
it that's incredible incredible now you
can also do this with other any video on
YouTube so this is this is um
okay let me find like uh let's go Grant
Cardone another Grant
so if I go to Grant Cardone
and we pull up this thing he did about
real estate predictions
so this is the video if you wanted to
share this video
you could take grants video
put the same Link at the end
and then it's going to put it inside
Brendan's playlist
oh wow so after Grant's video is done
we're going to watch 284 of Brendan
burchard videos wow
so for you if you want to share my video
or garyvee video or this inspirational
video that you found that's not yours
you then add your code at the end of it
and when that video finishes it'll just
auto start playing all of your videos
afterwards that's amazing
and you seem to get that link once like
that link that I copied was Brendan's
link right you got to get your link once
you have your channel we can set that up
and if you forget I can I can help you
again to do it but
um
yeah it's like a quick little setup and
then you put that at the end of any
video that you're going to share if
you're just send it to one person and
look look what I did actually I just
left my computer and the brand video is
still playing
right so I'm gonna end up watching like
40 Brendan Bouchard videos because I
forgot that I left it open which that
helps again with the YouTube algorithm
um if you send it to one person it
doesn't matter like don't worry about
adding the code if you just send it to
your friend but if you put it into a
newsletter or on social media where
multiple people could be looking at it
it all adds up for the watch time
is you know instead of hitting my
audience over the head with another
email about me I can say you know hey
check out this amazing video from Evan
Carmichael but Carmichael but they end
up going through my videos after that
anyway yeah so yeah yeah that's awesome
and it the link leads them to that video
yeah so they don't have to click
anything else they're still watching
that one video but then at the end all
of a sudden they just get put into the
playlist that's awesome yeah that's
amazing so every time you're sharing in
a newsletter or publicly you want to add
your link
um and then third thing quick is I would
look at if you really want to grow
quickly or look at a targeted ad
campaign yeah okay if you have a budget
to spend
um against different people's audiences
so on social or on YouTube YouTube okay
uh suggested video so video discovery
this pre-roll and Discovery pre-roll
means it shows up before somebody else's
video you don't want that Discovery
means it'll show up down the side
and so I would look at different videos
going to different people's audiences
okay so anything high performance
we're targeting Brendan's audience
anything real estate we're targeting
grants audience you know anything
sales maybe we're targeting Jordan's
audience or or uh you know like whoever
you think and it's got to be a big
player but if they only have a small
audience it's not worth doing
um anything entrepreneurship you could
Target my channel my audience and you
don't need access to be able to to do it
like you could just Target my audience
right now with any video that you've got
you just want to be cognizant if you did
a real estate video to my audience it
may not be as good as Grant Cardell
right sure
um and the little bonus on top of that
is if you get an interview with them you
definitely Target Their audience with
with those videos
um so yeah so you're consistently making
content with good titles that attract
attention we're using that link so
anywhere we share it outside of YouTube
we're putting people to a playlist and
then we're running targeted ads
um for each video that goes up with a
goal to gain views and subscribers a lot
of people when they do ads they just
pump up their numbers but it doesn't
convert to subscribers that's not what
we want like you buying a whole bunch
you could buy 40 000 views from somebody
in Argentina and you know great you got
views but it's not actually building
your audience
okay so I'd be looking at USA first but
maybe Canada U.S sorry Canada UK
Australia usually the other three
markets after U.S
um
and then hyper targeted for the video
you're going after again personal
development high performance Brendan you
just pick or Tony Robbins like those
topics you pick and you can just create
different categories like addiction
might be somebody else I don't know who
the who the leading addiction channel
would be
um
yeah so if you've got a budget it's a
faster way to hack the growth
that's amazing that's amazing cool
because I wasn't sure where to put the
video so and then do I take the same
video from YouTube and also put it as a
video blog on my website and It All
Leads back to the same place right you
can if you're gonna put it on your
website I would don't do it as an embed
yeah do it as a oh this is an even bonus
bonus so most people do it as an
embedded link right so you can actually
watch the video on your website
so you can like click play and they're
still on your website yeah don't do that
um YouTube
heavily discounts embedded views they
count for almost nothing they want you
on YouTube yeah so what you should do is
have the have a thumbnail like a big
thumbnail to say hey watch the video
with the play button and when they click
it it goes to YouTube
so leave your site and they go to in a
new window and they go to YouTube
and even even extra bonus on top of that
is that link also has your playlist code
at the end yeah
so then they're watching all of your
videos after
and if I'm any good I can have faith
that they're going to come back to my
website to learn more
because you load it in a new tab
right yeah so they have to close that
top and then there's your website again
okay okay so it's not like they've
really left my site because that's the
fear right
is that okay
amazing thank you
that's your 2021 plan sweet thank you
I'm on it I'm building it I'll be uh
yeah I'll be on our um I'll call and
I'll report back I love it all right
grant cheering you on man thank you very
much I appreciate it yeah take care see
ya to see me coaching another
entrepreneur one-on-one check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there to build a happy little
Consulting business you can do it that's
the path is already there it's easy to
let people have done it a lot of people
actually at half a million it's enough
it's like a lot of people their ambition
actually really slows down when they hit
that half a million half a million 300
000 half a million it's enough